nach dem pisasock in Deutschland haben
wir jetzt die Lehrpläne vollkommen
modernisiert wir gucken uns das mal an
Kinder wir gehen jetzt mit der Zeit pack
die Schiefertafeln Weg wir haben jetzt
pa Pyros für alle los geht's mit
schwerterschmieden und Kampf an der
Lanze für die Mädels Gil Waschbretter
raus ab an die Spray ich weiß das haben
wir uns schon alle gefragt heute klären
wir die Frage endlich wie Fall ich nicht
von der Erde runter bitte nehmt für die
schwertkampfklausur eure eigenen Rüstung
mit ich will nichts hören von kann ich
da mal reinschlüpfen bei dir heute im
Fach wie mache ich Gott glücklich Qual
der Wahl Wahl der Qual Grundkurs
folterkunde achtung das Fach ist der
letzte Schrei ihr wolltet dass wir euch
besser aufs Leben vorbereiten deswegen
jetzt Bücher auf Alchemie ich habe ja
schon gesagt ich habe eine Überraschung
für euch aufgrund der großen Nachfrage
können wir jetzt endlich anbieten
Leistungskurs
Hexenverbrennung